[Music]
pilot to Bombardier it's Father's Day
have you seen any missing links up there
pilot to Bombardier
you
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey him with his [ __ ] robe to
wish you [ __ ] and your families a
happy Father's Day
you don't Sam listen I'm very fortunate
to have 10 million nephews like you
[ __ ] so you have 10 million
nephews you gotta be an outstanding
[ __ ] uncle and I'm here to tell you I
appreciate all you dirty [ __ ]
now listen you could show up with a
plant or a dye was some for the Jew if
you show up with some of this [ __ ]
Paris og you'll blow his [ __ ] money
anything I woke you guys up quite as
camp I'm ready to [ __ ] rock I blew
Church off today I'm a smoking dope for
the last half hour I figured let me see
what my boys adore now say my girls
the Sun it's a beautiful [ __ ] there
would be alive if I mean I didn't [ __ ]
five-year today
you better batter on balls and shave
that [ __ ] [ __ ] check does that he's
gonna get to you little onions gonna
smell like a [ __ ] humping after that
basketball game gymnast then what who
gives a [ __ ]
we got kid to do this Paris og is
unfuckin fire today
so were you the sun's out the bird chirp
you have the family of families me maybe
you don't have a [ __ ] family maybe
you can eat by yourself whatever the
[ __ ] it is you gotta have a good day
three of us stay focused
who gives a [ __ ] you gotta go up there
swing think with three hands your net
though time to [ __ ] bleed [ __ ] these
[ __ ] everybody's walking around
I'm getting at I mean one you robbing a
purse to follow me
oh yeah
the best the best good Reaper
some good reaping soldier rieflin nice
little Hartmann [ __ ] fruit smoothie
with a half a banana in it we will see
meet the oil some cold water with ice
cubes frigid the metabolism gone I'm
[ __ ] ready this a mother [ __ ]
understand me
yeah look at
that smokes coming from my [ __ ] soul
you understand me
blowing it right to the Airways gets
right to your [ __ ] eyeballs my
eyeballs are starting to feel hot from
here in Chinese voices from hearing
ambulances this weeds on fire
it's 8:00 a.m. my go-to jiu-jitsu I'm
hang out with the family
I watched a baby the sample only got a
barbecue we had a podcast at night you
know how we do it daughter never [ __ ]
ants but hey if you stop moving you stop
[ __ ] the breeze and stuff you gotta
keep movin man
there's this ship to kill Kevin II
understand
got some black label look a bowl of that
too
it's a little cool card day if you see
I'm very well that's very very chill
pretty uncle you can't come out here
yellow [ __ ] screaming every day
there's gotta be a little semblance in
your life from time to time Joey you're
53 year old man smoking dope blow it
[ __ ] clowns who better than me but he
won't make you quit now what kind of
message with that Santa cycle with
smokin reefer like what everything else
I quit Rob and I quit [ __ ] at blah like
with even [ __ ] Puma nose like
whatever the name I am pardon [ __ ] at
hand and you still [ __ ] looking at me
like Joey what the [ __ ]
but you know that's the beauty of this
whole thing I got my goals ready I got
my toenails clipped and that's it I'm
gonna put some [ __ ] and I fumbled how
much woman yesterday the public grew you
never know what those [ __ ]
[Applause]
my fungi toe is on fire
that's it it's me and you against the
world concepts who's better than us
nobody
and that's it and that's that
but take a shower wash my [ __ ]
McDougal our right
that's it that's my [ __ ] flowers there
all this [ __ ] beep wood jumpin up
but it look feels good to be a father
you know for years I had a kid named
[ __ ] send me a paper clip my father's
mess the way it works out some people
[ __ ] animal but now I got a second
chance I created my own little [ __ ]
family
I gotta tell you [ __ ] it feels
good second chances of [ __ ] what
life's all about [ __ ] and if you
don't seize them
you slip because you always kind of
[ __ ] second chance I don't give it
from what they type I lost a million
[ __ ] jokes
I had arrested a thousand times what are
you gonna do you get a [ __ ] second
chance and that's what today is about
I feel good about getting a second
chance man and half of us because they
you thought serviced Joey what's with
the [ __ ] long-winded story drop that
reefer smoke on me
leather [ __ ] means
[Applause]
great most important thing is I got a
smile my face if you don't like this
mind your face from kind of day you can
I have come Zak
I was it getting a lot angered my heart
over the years you peel it and your
[ __ ] car comes up and you're back
okay but what do you all we can do is
stay healthy be different people
motion briefer and put it out there
that's it everything else if not it
falls into place I can't lie to you
people I am gonna take a [ __ ] nap on
so storms then I'll get up and wash my
[ __ ] but I love you guys see you
tonight eight o'clock the Church of
what's happening now fairly sold out
this weekend thanks to you guys without
you [ __ ] I go nuts
that's it
have a good day concept stay black